بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد يقول الحافظ النووي
في كتاب رياض الصالحين في باب الصبر وعن
انس رضي الله عنه قال قال رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم لا يتمنين احدكم الموت لضر
اصابه
فان كان لا بد فاعلا فليقل اللهم احيني ما
كانت الحياه خيرا لي وتوفني اذا كانت
الوفاه خيرا لي متفق عليه
الصالحين الحافظ النووي
انس رضي الله عنهم ابو حمزه انس بن مالك
رضي الله عنه
قال قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله صلى الله عليه
‏none of you
is to
ask for death or wish for death or pray
for death due to a difficulty that he is
encountering
due to a crisis due to a tribulation he
is being afflict with the word here يتمن
التمني
يطلق
ويراد به في القران الدعاء
ويراد به
التلاوه
وهنا في هذه الروايه يتمنين
واضح من كلام الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
ان المقصود ان الانسان يتمنى بقوله
ويتمنى بقلبه
فالانسان لا يدعو على نفسه بالموت
لا بلسانه
ولا بقلبه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
asking
sickness
fear
‏any
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتالى
صلى الله عليه
فان كان لابد فاعلا يعني ان كان لابد ان
يقول شيئا ان يدعو بشيء
فليقل
اللهم احييني ما كانت الحياه خيرا لي
وتوفني اذا كانت الوفاه خيرا ليه
[Silence]
هذه الدعوه
والعلماء اختلفوا هل يجوز للانسان ان يدعو
بهذه الدعوه في حال
اليسر ام هو فقط في حال العسر الجواب
الدعاء جيد في حال المنشط والمكره في حال
اي اليسر او العسر
اذا لا باس
بان يدعو الداعي بهذه الدعوه الطيبه سواء
كان في ضراء ام في سراء
دعاء
‏time
الله
any
person make difficulty
صل الله عليه وسلمر
مريم عليه
يا ليتني مت قبل هذا وكنت نسيا منسيا
ما دعاء
قران مريم عليه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
صحيح البخاري
صلى الله عليه وسلم لا تقوم الساعه حتى
يمر الرجل بقبر رجل فيقول يا ليتني كنت
مكانك
من الفتنه من شده الفتنه على الدين
صلى الله عليه وسلم
another
‏only place to
people
الموت هنا لا المؤمن المؤمن هو الذي يقول
يا ليتني كنت مكانك
وليس به الا الفتنه الفتنه في ين يقول
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم فكيف نوفق بين
هذا وهذا
ابن كثير رحمه الله تفسير
inalthysical
‏is not necessarily strugling
in the
are
in the spirit
they fear for theirigion sake.
فتit
رحمه الله
initulation
ofysical of the
fit of
because of
‏no
here suff ever
why because when you here
fate has been sealed
صلى الله عليه وسلم
however
in hereaning
areay
this is ait which is perm to ask for
death in this case to make
ان شاء الله نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه
وكرمه وجوده ان يقين الفتن ما ظهر منها
وما بطن اساله تعالى ان يقدرنا على جميع
ما ابتلانا به نساله تعالى ان ينهبنا صبرا
جميلا والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا محمد